[Musica]
[Applauso]
lui pedologi italiani abbiamo una grande
responsabilità ed è quella di proteggere
i suoli del paese più bello del mondo
questa frase non è mia ma del professor
mancini ed è per questa frase che ho
deciso anni fa di occuparmi dello studio
e della protezione del suolo
il mio intento è quello di cercare di
trasferire anche a voi un pò di questa
curiosità e di questa sensibilità in
questi anni ho avuto occasione di
viaggiare di visitare molti luoghi
vedere osservare la varietà e la
ricchezza dei suoli del nostro paese e
soprattutto osservare quanta bellezza e
si sostengano il rapporto che noi tutti
abbiamo col suolo il più delle volte un
rapporto assolutamente marginale ci
limitiamo a calpestarlo calpestarlo
quando facciamo magari una passeggiata
in campania o quando andiamo al parco e
magari siamo infastiditi per il fango
che ci si attacca alla suola delle
scarpe che portiamo nelle nostre case e
quindi la percezione di quanto il solo
per noi sia importante non è così
immediata sarebbe probabilmente più
semplice capire quanto sia importante e
indispensabile l'acqua un elemento come
l'acqua che noi beviamo tutti i giorni
quotidianamente o l'aria che respiriamo
in continuazione ma vi assicuro che al
suolo è altrettanto importante la fa o
ci ricorda che il 95 per cento oltre 95
per cento degli alimenti che soddisfano
i fabbisogni alimentari del pianeta
proviene dal suolo
ma quello che vi vorrei ricordare che il
suolo non è solo questo il solo è molto
molto di più
il suono sostiene la biodiversità la
biodiversità nelle forme in cui la
conosciamo quella che sta sopra al suolo
cioè le piante e gli animali che noi
osserviamo ma soprattutto all'interno
del suolo è contenuta una quantità
impressionante di biodiversità
pensate che in una manciata di suolo
quella che vedete qui in questa immagine
sono contenuti
milioni di specie viventi milioni di
organismi viventi in forma la
microscopica sono batteri sono funghi o
appena organismi appena più grandi come
insetti e lombrichi
considerate che le stime ci dicono che
nel suolo all'interno dei suoli di tutto
il pianeta e contenuto circa un terzo
dell'intera biodiversità di tutto il
pianeta e gran parte di questa
biodiversità di queste forme di vita
sono sconosciute non sono ancora
conosciute e sappiamo che molte funzioni
ad esempio la ricerca di nuovi
antibiotici partono da da questi
organismi che popolano i suoli il suono
in realtà e tanto altro ancora li
chiamiamo servizi ecosistemici ma
pensate solo all'azione che il suolo a
nel regolare la qualità e la quantità
dell'acqua c'è il ciclo dell'acqua
oppure la capacità che al suolo di
mitigare il cambiamento climatico
noi sappiamo che l'anidride carbonica
che le piante possono trattenere e
trasferire al suolo in forma di sostanza
organica può contribuire a ridurre gli
effetti a mitigare il cambiamento
climatico e poi il suolo e tanto altro
ancora e produzione di legname di
biomasse utili all'uomo ma è soprattutto
paesaggio putt paesaggio e sostegno alle
molteplici attività che l'uomo svolge ma
la domanda a questo punto è se di suolo
ce ne è abbastanza o o se sia
sufficiente o meno per i 7,6 miliardi di
persone che popolano il pianeta oggi e
per i loro fabbisogni o per i 9 miliardi
di persone che popoleranno a breve la
terra e che avranno fa bisogni crescenti
allora quanto solo abbiamo teoricamente
tanto tanto nel senso che se ci basiamo
sulle sulla superficie delle terre
emerse sulla superficie dei continenti
abbiamo quasi 150 milioni di chilometri
quadrati
quindi sembra una grandissima quantità
ma se facciamo un'analisi un po più di
dettaglio e ci chiediamo ad esempio
quanto suolo fertile abbiamo quanto
suolo di buona qualità adatto a fare
agricoltura produrre cibo ci rendiamo
conto che ne abbiamo molto meno ne
abbiamo molto meno e le stime parlano
approssimativamente di una quota
compresa tra il 13 e il 18 per cento di
terreni intrinsecamente fertili
naturalmente fertili e considerate che
la metà di questi suoli sono già
attualmente coltivati e soprattutto
considerate che è in questi suoli che si
concentrano gran parte delle attività
dell'uomo
e cosa succede che laddove si
concentrano le attività antropiche
purtroppo ci sono dei fenomeni che
conosciamo come processi di degradazione
del suolo che vengono innescati o
perlomeno intensificati dall'azione
dell'uomo questi fenomeni sono
l'erosione dei suoli ad esempio o la
contaminazione dovuta a un uso eccessivo
di di fitofarmaci o all'accumulo di
sostanze pericolose di rifiuti o
all'accumulo di sali o la perdita di
sostanze organiche alla compattazione ma
tra tutti questi processi
quello di cui vi vorrei parlare in
particolare questa sera quest'oggi è
quello che noi chiamiamo consumo di
suolo
ora col termine consumo di suolo è una
terminologia consolidata ormai ci
riferiamo a tutti quei processi con
quali l'uomo va a impermeabilizzare il
suolo ricoprendolo di cemento o di
asfalto cioè tutte le volte che noi
costruiamo costruiamo qualcosa edifici
costruiamo aree commerciali parcheggi
strade autostrade infrastrutture di
trasporto opere in alcuni casi è
assolutamente utili essenziali
non sempre però in tutti questi casi noi
andiamo a compromettere in modo
pressoché irreversibile
una risorsa che è preziosa essenziale e
non rinnovabile quindi dobbiamo tenere
in mente questo concetto è quanto suolo
abbiamo consuma consumato a livello a
livello
qual è il livello planetario qui vedete
questa mappa che mostra le aree l'indice
di urbanizzazione al 2000 quindi vedete
che con i colori rosso arancio giallo
abbiamo le aree più urbanizzate del
pianeta naturalmente alcune sono aree
sono corrispondono a paesi elevata
densità di popolazione altre aree sono
aree a magari con minore densità di
popolazione ma comunque a forte crescita
economica quello che vediamo invece se
andiamo ad analizzare quelli che sono il
trend cioè cosa sta succedendo negli
ultimi anni negli ultimi 15 anni
quanto suolo stiamo consumando adesso
questo processo questa mappa riprende un
po quello che abbiamo visto prima quindi
vediamo i paesi industrializzati paesi
occidentali ma troviamo anche i paesi le
economie emergenti come la cina o
l'india o i paesi a forte crescita
demografica come la nigeria ma purtroppo
troviamo anche dei paesi che in questo
periodo di tempo c'è negli ultimi 15
anni non hanno avuto né crescita
demografica né crescita economica ma
ugualmente hanno consumato suolo vuoi
per fenomeni speculativi voi per altre
cause e sono ad esempio alcuni dei paesi
europei quanto terreno abbiamo consumato
a livello globale negli ultimi 15 anni
abbiamo consumato mezza italia metà
italia e cioè 145 mila chilometri
quadrati di terreno sono stati coperti
negli ultimi 15 anni da asfalto e
cemento
questo corrisponde ad aver sacrificato
la capacità di poter produrre 60 milioni
di tonnellate di frumento o di cereali
equivalenti a mille navi mercantili
carichi di cereali che sono il
fabbisogno alimentare di 600 milioni di
abitanti
questi processi naturalmente come vi
dicevo sono particolarmente intensi in
aree caratterizzate da elevata crescita
economica e demografica
se facciamo un'analisi ad esempio di una
parte della cina
in questa carta vedete una parte della
cina compresa tra pechino e shanghai
e guardiamo quale sia stato il consumo
di suolo nel periodo nei 20 anni che
vanno dal 1992 al 2012
vediamo che questo fenomeno ha avuto e
dimensioni assolutamente preoccupanti
tant'è che la cina è arrivata a
formulare delle leggi per assicurare la
sicurezza alimentare al proprio paese
come figura l'italia in questa
classifica l'italia non sfigura il che è
ironico sarebbe come dire che in realtà
facciamo la nostra figura ma in termini
negativi cioè vuole dire che l'italia in
termini di consumo assoluto di suolo si
colloca al di al decimo posto
quindi l'italia negli ultimi 15 anni pur
non avendo avuto crescite economiche
particolarmente elevate o né tantomeno
crescita demografica ha continuato a
consumare suolo e se guardiamo la
situazione
facciamo il confronto anni cinquanta
2015 vediamo che negli anni cinquanta al
2,7 per cento del paese era urbanizzato
e siamo arrivati al 7 per cento nel 2015
è vero in questo periodo c'è stata la
crescita economica c'è stato il boom
economico ma non c'è stata tanta
crescita demografica ma soprattutto in
questo periodo la crescita delle aree
urbanizzate e stata del 159 per cento
è come se ci fossimo mangiati l'umbria e
il molise messi assieme
e quello che vorrei ricordarvi che
soprattutto consumo di suolo non vuol
dire io avevo parlato della relazione
tra consumo di suolo e produzione
alimentare ma non è solo questo
consumare suolo vuol dire impatto sul
paesaggio impatti che noi tutti
conosciamo in molti casi vuol dire
impatto sulla sicurezza idraulica del
territorio
e i fenomeni che ai quali siamo abituati
molto spesso ce lo ricordano
naturalmente non sono causati solo dal
consumo di suolo ma anche da altre cause
consumo di suolo vuol dire impatto sul
clima quindi accentuare l'effetto del
cambiamento climatico e consumo di suolo
significa anche impatti sulla
biodiversità
ora non vorrei dare solo messaggi
negativi perché in realtà noi cosa
possiamo fare possiamo fare tanto
possiamo fare veramente tanto anche con
le nostre scelte di cittadini di
consumatori con le nostre scelte
individuali e quotidiane li faccio degli
esempi ad esempio tutte le volte che
scegliamo la mobilità sostenibile quindi
decidiamo di limitare il nostro ricorso
ai mezzi motorizzati automaticamente
andiamo a ridurre quelli che sono i
fabbisogni di nuove strade nuove
infrastrutture per la mobilità diciamo
non sostenibile mobilità motorizzata
tutte le volte che compiamo delle scelte
abitative o dove andare in vacanza come
fare oh quante case avere che
raccontiamo delle scelte che hanno un
impatto naturalmente sul consumo di
suolo
così come quando ci impegniamo a fare
una buona raccolta differenziata dei
rifiuti
magari questo legame non è così
immediato ma fare buona raccolta dei
rifiuti significa limitare la quantità
che va in discarica o comunque anche in
inceneritori ma che deve essere smaltita
e sottrarrà terreni che non potranno
essere utilizzati per altre funzioni
e ancora riducendo ad esempio lo spreco
alimentare anche questo perché produrre
cibo in eccesso e richiede richiede
territorio
o ancora il consumo di prodotti locali a
filiera corta anche questo riduce le
necessità di trasporto infrastrutture di
trasporti logistica e quindi
inevitabilmente riduce il nostro impatto
sul territorio e sull'ambiente
ma la cosa forse più significativa che
possiamo fare e quando noi deleghiamo il
nostro potere di cittadini di la nostra
rappresentanza ai nostri decisori
pubblici ai decisori politici col voto
cercando di evitare che
si ripetano episodi come questo questo
lo conoscete tutti perché è a due passi
da d'acqua ea due passi da casa nostra
ma purtroppo di esempi come questo ce ne
sono tantissimi in italia questo esempio
voi lo conoscete forse non devo dire più
di tanto
per adesso sono nove chilometri di
autostrada che si perdono nel nulla e
forse rimarranno persi nel nulla
sono opere che non hanno un significato
economico non hanno un non rispondono a
nessun fabbisogno reale con comportano
danni sull'ambiente e danni
sull'economia vi vorrei ora riassumere
le cose dette
spero di non tagliarmi perché questo
estremamente affilato richiama un po la
vostra fantasia dovete immaginare che
questo sia il nostro pianeta sia la
terra ora noi sappiamo che la terra è
costituita per per tre quarti dagli
oceani e quindi le terre emerse coprono
solo un quarto del pianeta
approssimativamente sappiamo anche altre
cose in realtà sappiamo che gran parte
del pianeta è coperto da ghiacci o è
caratterizzato da climi troppo freddi
può dare che hanno sono permanentemente
sature di acqua e quindi dobbiamo
scartare una buona parte delle terre
emerse
poi sappiamo che abbiamo altri ambienti
che sono ostili all'insediamento
dell'uomo le attività umane cioè aree
desertiche troppo aride o troppo calde
dove non si riesce a fare agricoltura
non ci si riesce nemmeno a vivere e
quindi dobbiamo escludere un'altra parte
rilevante del nostro pianeta delle terre
che abbiamo a disposizione e poi abbiamo
ancora le aree montane o quelle a
pendenza troppo elevata o che hanno
suoli troppo superficiali e quindi ne
dobbiamo togliere un altro pezzo
rilevante ora considerate che il suolo e
questa sottilissima pellicola che
ricopre il pianeta per un metro due
metri
persone quindi è come se a questo pezzo
di mela io tagliassi la la buccia e
questo è quello che serve all'umanità
per il proprio sostentamento nostro
alimentare quindi il mio invito e ad
avere cura di questo pezzettino che
rappresenta il suolo che abbiamo grazie
[Applauso]